so in case you haven't heard Godzilla
minus1 is getting a black and white
theatrical release soon and this thing
appears to be way more of a labor of
love than people were anticipating
Godzilla minus one was already an
absolute visual treat but when we heard
about this black and white release I
think a lot of people were expecting a
grayscale conversion with maybe a few
touch-ups here and there but now that we
have actual footage it appears this
thing is getting proper treatment
shadows and highlights are widened to
really bring out a filmic contrast look
seemingly on a scene by scene basis Mad
Max Fury Road also got a proper black
and white release and it appears this is
taking a very similar approach I'm not
always into black and white releases but
given how gorgeous minus one is I'm
really hoping this does well I mean come
on look at this poster how sick is it